language learning starts with you with
the person with the learner just do it
language learning to me is almost like a
model of life itself so many things can
happen to us in our lives what matters
is what we do and when we start
something that's the most important step
to do something and if we do something
it may trigger a series of events that
we didn't anticipate some might be
better than we hope for some might be
worse than we hope for but throughout my
life every time I have undertaken to do
something it has brought me some of the
greatest opportunities in my life when I
was I think 19 working on a construction
site in Montreal I was fired with that
particular section of the job had been
completed so I went down to the dock in
Montreal and three days I asked to see
the captain of the various ships that
were docked in Montreal Port asked to
work my way across to Europe day three I
found work on a German freighter called
the garretta shell a hairy see a picture
of me with my crew members and I work my
way across Europe I ended up in glenoble
in France and here is another situation
I had a very good friend who was a
Turkish student whose name was chapar
and I was studying English and French
didn't know what to study but he was
studying political science so I switched
over to political science and the
following year I went to sias Paul
lastituditude politique in Paris and got
a scholarship from the French government
eventually wrote my foreign service exam
there for the Canadian diplomatic
service was accepted so all of these
things came from my decision to go and
hitchhike on a boat across to Europe
similarly when I was with the Diplomatic
service I heard that they were looking
for someone to study Mandarin Chinese
because in 1968 Canada was getting ready
to recognize the People's Republic of
China they wanted to train some people
up in Chinese so I went and started
taking Chinese lessons I didn't learn
very much but I told my boss hey okay
I'm learning Chinese I'm your man why
wouldn't they choose me next thing you
know I'm in Hong Kong studying Chinese
prowling the bookstores for material
reading and listening and doing whatever
I can I mean I can go on and on and on
in my professional career how things
that I did whether it be in my
diplomatic career or in my career first
ever as a forest industry executive and
then an entrepreneur in the forest
industry very often it's not what I
expected would happen that ended up
happening but it was the fact that I did
something that caused opportunities to
come my way you know it's a bit like the
book that I listened to and read in
Danish live more think less we are
bombarded by thoughts all day long 50
000 thoughts apparently some are good
some are bad some people dwell on the
negative thoughts and some of them end
up with depression it's how we choose to
deal with these thoughts it's our belief
system that determines how we cope with
these thoughts and the same is true in
language learning you know you may not
be tremendously motivated to learn
Spanish or Japanese and you start on it
and you may find something there that
motivates you to continue or you may
meet people through Having learned or
studied that language it's just as
possible that you will be motivated then
to move to another language in other
words that initial impetus to learn
language a might lead you to learn
language B the important thing is to do
something to get started as the French
say La Petite
so there are so many examples of this in
my life but I thought of it with
specific reference to language learning
many people say well I have no talent I
was never any good well maybe you should
just give it a chance push on it a
little bit see what happens push on that
door it may open it may not but maybe in
trying to learn this language you will
meet some people or you will find
another language that interests you or
even something else unrelated to
language but the main thing is
everything that happens to us in our
lives we're surrounded by opportunities
but what matters is whether we do
something and the more active we are the
greater number of these opportunities
will come our way including the fact
that the more languages we know the
greater the number of opportunities that
are going to come our way so I just
wanted to talk a little more generally
about the importance of being proactive
in our lives do it as that Nike
advertising slogan went thanks for
listening